[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous racontent la vie des
acteurs économiques du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
al'approche de noël les jeux de société
un peuvent être une idée de cadeau et
justement nous sommes chez exode games
cette société est situé à guyancourt
elle est spécialisée dans l'édition de
jeux de société avec notamment son
best-seller jurassique world découverte
de cette entreprise juste après ce
sommaire du 7ème numéro du sky est qu en
face à la crise sanitaire la start-up
exode guèye s'est appuyé sur les ventes
de ses jeux de société déjà développé
découverte aussi de ses best-sellers
pour ce noël 2020
elle fabrique des sacs des sacoches ou
des bagages une voile de bateau des
idées de cadeaux conçu par valérie vial
elle est la dirigeante de la voilerie
atelier couture à elancourt enfin focus
sur la collaboration entre m 2 ième et
airbus cybersécurité sur la sécurisation
d'un système d'éclairage public
intelligent exode games est une start up
créée en 2010 est à montigny le
bretonneux je vous le disais allez
spécialisée dans l'édition de jeux de
société et depuis sa création elle a
multiplié par trois son chiffre
d'affaires
[Musique]
non
et pour parler de cette réussite nous
sommes avec la dirigeante d'exode game
hélène barral bonjour alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut retrouver sous le sapin pour
ce noël 2020 cette année la plus grosse
annonce qu'on a chez exane games et des
gobies nano petit gobelins favoris
notamment le petit gobelins qui était
offert à tous les gens pour noël qui le
perdent gobelins et panique une bière
pour les amoureux de parachutisme donc
ces dons sont des jeux déjà développé un
voilà ils sont produits ils ont très
bien marché cette année et ce sont des
choses qui sont pour les parents pour
les enfants et qui sont assez rapides
moins de 20 minutes 30 minutes si vous
êtes un peu un peu débutants mais dont
les délais très rapides avec cette année
2001 très particulière une crise
sanitaire comment vous avez résisté à
cette crise les ventes ont aidés donc
les jeux de société ont été un des
succès phare de cette année plus que les
gens étant confiné ont développé un peu
plus leur goût pour les jeux les jeux de
société et du coup les jeux qui était
déjà produit ont beaucoup se sont
beaucoup vendu on fait des ruptures si
on a dû reproduire et par contre ce qui
a été plus difficile c'est pour les jeux
qui devait sortir cette année qui ont
subi des retards de production notamment
parce que du coup les conditions ont
fait que certaines usines ont dû fermer
temporairement en chine ou en europe que
on n'a pas tout le monde disponible dans
les locaux pour développer constamment
le clae trail peut-être aussi un frein
pour pour développer et du coup c'est
eux qui sont pas sortis cette année qui
sortiront l'année prochaine donc ils ont
pris à peu près entre six mois
entre trois et six mois de retard de
production et ceux qui sont en
développement également très peu près le
même le même temps de retard alors on
était venu vous voir en début d'année
pour votre produit phare c'est
jurassique world développé avec
universal comment ça s'est passé par
rapport à ce jeu du coup alors c'est lui
qui a eu le plus de retard puisqu'il le
malheureusement il a besoin de trois
entreprises différentes pour être créés
et donc ceux qui font les moules des
figurines l'entreprise qui le fabrique
en chine et le transporteur qui le
transporte
et du coup il l'est il a pris du retard
ils étaient prêts pour septembre et
aujourd'hui il sera livré en premier
trimestre de 2021 de janvier et c'est
lui qui a pris le plus gros retard mais
c'est aussi la plus grosse vente depuis
vous avez multiplié votre chiffre
d'affaires par trois cette année 2020
va-t-elle plombé un peu cette croissance
alors forcément on a subi un peu de
perte de croissance de perte de vitesse
mais on a dû aussi se serrer les coudes
entre éditeurs donc ça c'est quelque
chose que qui est très très commun au
milieu ludique puisque l'on est toujours
là les uns pour les autres
mais on a décidé de repartir d'encore
plus belles l'année prochaine donc avec
la sortie de d'une vingtaine de jeux
l'avantagé au moins d'avoir subi des
retards c'est qu'on a pu se poser
repartir sur de nouvelles bases
alors avant de parler justement du futur
des prochaines sorties à un mot sur
justement cette collaboration commence à
ces faits concrètement cette
collaboration entre éditeurs ces issues
en fait de jurassic à la base un éditeur
qui m'a contacté en me disant qu'il
aurait bien aimé me apporter son aide
sur le projet parce que il en était fan
et sortir des projets
un ex dessus notamment avec la corde
universal et au fur et à mesure on a
apporté mutuellement notre aide
on a eu un gros investisseur qui a cru
en nous et qui a dit je me joins à l
aventure donc dans la société ge et la
cité jade et on s'est regroupés pour
créer bic et qu'il sera oblet l'année
prochaine et qui du coup a prévu de
faire du transverse et permet d'aider
donc les jeux vidéo les jeux de société
et un peu d'autres surprises de l'année
prochaine et donc justement l'avenir est
plutôt optimiste pour examiner l'avenir
est très optimiste alors malheureusement
peut-être pas forcément pour la marque
exode gamestm est plutôt fulham a
parce qu'on a pris du coup a vraiment
émergé pour devenir beach mais l'essence
même du check the game est donc ya pas
de petit copain et tout ça ça se passe à
guyancourt sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines merci et le baram
rtm dirigeante de exode games
[Musique]
autre idée de cadeau des accessoires des
sacs des porte monnaie ou encore des
sacoches fabriqué à la main à partir de
voiles de bateau
c'est l'activité de valérie vial cet
élan courtoise et maître voilier
découverte de sa société la voilerie
atelier couture dans ma vie
d'entrepreneur
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle 20 et riviane je
suis la dirigeante de la voile slovaque
basé à elancourt est créée en 2010
[Musique]
je suis maître voilier c'est à dire se
dit maître voilier quand on a 15 ans
d'expérience donc je crée des voiles
quel que soit le bateau après je
m'occupe de l'intérieur du bateau et
tous les accessoires qui compte
constitue le bateau est peu après à tous
qui réparation de voile de kitesurf de
porsche en voile du char à voile
tout ce qui est en bord de mer en règle
générale
à force de faire de la couture mais en
voile du coup j'ai bien apprécié ce que
la diversité des coutures et tout ce
qu'on peut faire et du coup j'ai créé ma
société y à pas par envie puis par
passion
car ce noël des produits phares et ben
d'abord je recycle beaucoup donc des
sacs des pochettes des des articles pour
la piscine c'est à dire les coussins
tout ce qui est cher longue mais
chilienne les poufs les tabourets ça
peut être beaucoup beaucoup de choses
comme ça
[Musique]
les résultats d'un ne sont pas comme
d'habitude donc on verra les résultats
en fin d'année là il ya eu qu un ou deux
marchés de réaliser donc
les finances sont pas bonnes cette année
mais c'est pas un souci on attendra les
prochaines à voilerie survie à covin
encore y'a pas de problème
[Musique]
et
on poursuivi ce sky aequo avec une
collaboration le groupe airbus
cybersécurité la start-up m 2 ième
prévoit de développer ensemble des
solutions pour les jeux olympiques de
en attendant ils ont participé en commun
un projet baptisé pack lido
l'intégration de systèmes de
cybersécurité dans des objets connectés
c'est la séquence business sky entre le
groupe airbus et la start-up m 2 ième
[Musique]
et
m tout y est
m ou 2 ième est une start up donc qui a
été créée en 2015
l'intégrateur de systèmes haïti et
notamment pour la gestion de l'éclairage
public
[Musique]
le projet pak lido est un projet
d'innovation airbus cyber security a
travaillé avec saint quentin en yvelines
ainsi que sept autres
sept autres partenaires au travers d'un
cas du visage de d'éclairage intelligent
visant à des capacités de contrôle et
les lampadaires à distance on a mis à
disposition notre savoir et notre
système existant on était à la recherche
d'un partenaire qui connaissait le
fonctionnement des lampadaires
intelligents des systèmes d'éclairage
intelligent pour pouvoir mener cette
expérimentation temps réel ça s'est fait
par l'intermédiaire de sky
puisque nous avions déjà une
expérimentation sur l'éclairage public
c'est comme ça qu'on a rencontré
notamment au travers de l'incubateur de
saint quentin en yvelines le sky cure là
la start-up m2 ayem qui répondait
parfaitement aux critères de technologie
et aussi de réactivité
une collaboration excellente 6ème 2ième
a été extrêmement réactif et nous a
permis de mettre en place ce
démonstrateur rapidement on a bénéficié
de cet environnement d'experts expert
sécurité et aliotti pour pouvoir
vraiment améliorer notre système
c'est un succès technologique aussi on a
ainsi pu établir et construire une
solution d'éclairage intelligent
hautement sécurisé ça nous a permis de
gagner en maturité et de progresser d'un
point de vue sécurité avec la
multiplication des grands projets
d'infrastructures et des chantiers
d'intervention le groupe est né dix
rencontres des besoins de recrutement
dans la région ile de france ouest et
notamment dans les yvelines
le gestionnaire de réseau de
distribution électrique embauches
notamment des techniciens d'intervention
polyvalent c'est la séquence elle
recrute avec alice
[Musique]
je m'appelle karine la guardia je suis
la déléguée ressources humaines de la
direction ene 10 en ile de france ouest
et actuellement nous recrutons des
emplois de techniciens d'intervention
polyvalente
cette activité consiste à venir dépanner
intervenir chez le client
assurer la maintenance et de
développement du réseau de distribution
d'électricité
vous avez des techniciens effectivement
qui peuvent remonter aux poteaux c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qu'on dit et qui
peuvent réaliser des l'interventions
d'électricité l'entreprise est née 17
une suggestion aire de distribution
d'énergie aux services publics de
distribution d'énergie
c'est ainsi qu'une entreprise qui offre
des perspectives professionnelles
importantes
vous pouvez très bien rentrer dans
l'entreprise en tant que technicien et
si vous êtes motivés si vous avez envie
d'évoluer
vous pouvez accéder à toutes sortes de
métiers on donne une offre de
professionnalisation et de formation
important
un technicien polyvalent dans son antre
et de poste il avoisine les 24000 euros
annuels en termes de rémunération brute
on recherche des jeunes diplômés 1
alors on vide et des diplômes allant du
ceap et au bac + 5
les jeunes diplômés mais également on
peut aussi recruter des personnes qui
ont de l'expérience
pas forcément vos diplômes et ce qu'on
recherche principalement c'est des
salariés qui ont un bon savoir être qui
ont envie de s'investir dans des
missions de service public
une publions nos offres sur enodis
recrute donc elles sont mises en ligne
il suffit donc de s'inscrire à être
conviés date est bien un ordinateur
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile passer de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année et à bientôt sur tv